all right we have passed through this
question yeah so let's do it sine theta
equals R on el L so therefore i can just
say that our that's the thing i'm after
remember above trio are our is going to
be l sine theta right 1.4 so politics
yes so the radius is bees good what was
I using that again for okay good i can
pop that into this guy down right Teddy
2 equals the line so i can say but tan
theta equals R Omega squared on G so I
know it theories it's fine on six I just
worked out what the radius was 0.7 Omega
is what I'm trying to find out right now
I think yeah they're a bit naughty the
questions should define what genius
sorry I just haven't finished or
something the questions should define G
ok but I went through and I double
checked on on their numbers ok they're
expecting us to use jeepers like with it
ok oh now in an exam context you will
never have to worry about this because
one of two things will happen not one
I'm number one they'll say answer in
terms of G or they'll tell you what you
use ok but this is it's an exercise they
just be like you know go through the
process the number itself doesn't matter
at the end but this is just so you make
sure you get the rising ok so i'm just
going to write um if g equals nine point
ok ok what shall I do
divided I know you can evaluate the time
yep 10.6 years come on wish do this with
me one over three very good one common
root 3 i'm going to at the same time get
all of this stuff over this site so
that's 9.8 on northpoint Senate this is
omega squared so a big is going to be
the square root of 9.8 10.7 root 3 the
case isn't matter if it's positive or
negative because either way you're going
to get angular that's exactly right so
I'm just going to say for this value
like for this one okay okay all right
you got number for me okay sir yeah oh
wait amazing that she of course yes fine
actually I'm not done yet I'm not done
yet because remember so let's climb back
up this red ladder why do i what Omega
in the first place to find the period ok
so the period is 2 pi on Omega so it's a
2 pi on this thing 2 pi on the square
root of and now this is the thing that
we're ready to evaluate 2.21 what no
it's not
yeah okay you told me we worked out
radians per second radians per second
and then you divided a number of radians
by radians per second to the radiance
kettle and the seconds went from the
denominator de Mayo up to the top okay
pitchers and also it's a plane it's a
tie okay all right so far so good are
you with me so far make sense now I
think that was the hardest part of a
question the rest of this is actually
not that hard we're on the downhill
because remember we noted this before
and well oh we can't use it yet because
we don't know what Omega is but now we
do know so we can use this to find out
the tension okay this is just a
substitution in fact it's so simple i'm
just going to chuck it up here tension
is equal to what if I got here mass
length so this is 14 right 10 x 1.4
times that that's right squared right so
that's just going to be x 9.8 10.7 root
3 yes when you go ahead and you can
crunch this through right you get this
this messy number okay but why in the
textbook they're just going back to you
have gone back to this right which is
like anyway it's like I like it
sometimes I don't like it other times I
think the only reason why I justify this
why are justified from their point of
view is because we don't think of x in
terms of gravity or we gently kotaku
it's like I want to know how long and I
just want a number whereas we do think
of forces in terms of gravity and that's
quite so that's the only way I'm going
to justify it i can simplify this just a
little bit because this is um if i put
if i multiply the top and bottom by 10
that's going to be 140g 173 so I would
probably write this I mean you could
rationalize that denominator
it's not what this question is about
okay having happy anyways yeah exactly
it's like yeah yeah you haven't got all
the way through this so what rotten
what's the point okay all right let's
just before we move on to number two
remember the hard part of this was we've
got this down go our diagram down and in
to work these aren't you must carefully
think about what is it you need and what
do you have to feed into this right and
so I think this is a critical part sorry
oh yes thank you done